dans quelques semaines ou bien demain
ils vont devoir monter à la son ces
hommes de la 102e brigade de défense
territoriale n'ont rien à envier à
l'armée ukrainienne ils font tous la
guerre depuis plus d'un an loin de chez
eux des volontaires venus de l'Ouest qui
ont repoussé d'une dizaine de kilomètres
cet hiver les Russes de leur position au
sud de vaporiser
depuis le roulement du canon était tout
fait par les frondaisons avec le
printemps le rythme des entraînements
s'accélère
eux sont de l'infanterie légère leur
mission s’est lancée vers les
fortifications ennemies
des centaines de kilomètres de tranchées
ont été creusés dans les territoires
occupés
l'entrée dans le bunker super le plus
important c'est que vous ayez crier
on essaie de réduire un programme de
deux mois en deux semaines seulement
c'est pour cela que nous avons beaucoup
de groupes qui tournent
l'Ukraine est enrôlé plus de 40 000
hommes ces derniers mois à mesure qu'il
s'approche de la ligne de contact il
poursuivent leur formation et mesurent
aussi leur appréhension nous savons
qu'ils ont beaucoup miné les lignes de
défense et qu'ils attendent notre
contre-offensive pour nous qui sommes
une unité de reconnaissance c'est ce qui
nous fait le plus peur car les mines
causes 90% de nos pertes
une contre-offensive qui pourrait être
lancée sans appuyer rien au risque
d'exposer d'autant plus hommes et
blindés
personne n'a jamais combattu un tel
ennemi qui a la suprématie dans les airs
qui a plus de temps que d'artillerie et
encore plus d'armes lourdes mais nous
leur faisons face avec notre
intelligence notre ruse et nos tactiques
les combats
des unités les pertes côté ukrainien
sont un secret bien gardé sur la ligne
de front longue de 900 km il y aurait
plus de 150 000 soldats à Ukrainiens
face à eux d'être trop russe qui
seraient deux à trois fois supérieur en
nombre dans toutes les régions occupées
une infériorité numérique qui pourrait
être une difficulté pour exploiter une
percée pour pallier à cela l'armée
ukrainienne mise sur la formation de ses
soldats et leur motivation